Chris ber and Chris rufo published
evidence that Claudine gay had
plagiarized significant portions of her
dissertation within 48 Hours the
Washington Free Beacon followed up with
many more examples of Gaye plagiarism
including entire paragraphs that she
lifted for some of her peer reviewed
Publications and all of this snowballed
over the course of a few weeks and then
yesterday as you've probably heard
Claudine gay finally resigned Chris over
at substack was able to post about
Claudine Gay's corruption not because he
had any special insight necessarily not
because he had any like information that
was given to him some secret information
but only because he was one of the only
people who were brave enough to publish
what hundreds of academics have been
saying in private for years